um
with the uh extended version of the
project coming out the deluxe version
what's your favorite out of those new
six they're all my babies man
all of them yeah i'm emotional that's
fair i mean it's
it's gotta be harder i mean like it's a
it would be like the end of the day
there's a reason why they made the album
because i'm sure you had like 30 other
songs you could have choose yeah no
actually yeah it's been like 30 deluxes
that's what i'm saying yeah so those had
to be the six that you love no i mean
like
a [ __ ] with dirt heavy you feel me i
[ __ ] with they
like like his homies and [ __ ] is my
homies like said like c3
and sparrow and all the [ __ ] like do
the load
like you feel me i mean it's good it's i
mean look dirk right now is on fire bro
yeah but not even on no dick riding [ __ ]
cause a lot of [ __ ] be trying to get
close to [ __ ] because of what [ __ ]
got going on
it ain't even about that like i
literally like
like you feel me i literally [ __ ] with
them and just like
be at the studio i'll be with them knees
like right we
ordered me some food too fool right it's
good like that like
like i [ __ ] with them [ __ ] so like
it's cool like big zoo all of them
[ __ ] like
i'd be cool with them and i'm not saying
that i'm best friends with them [ __ ]
but
right like you was on that show in a z
that like fake got shot
up but he didn't actually get shot up
someone just dropped the mic
yo that [ __ ] was late that [ __ ] looked
like a [ __ ]
she was crazy that [ __ ] looked like a
hot ass mess people was getting trampled
all kind of [ __ ] that was like
robbed and all kind of stuff yo that was
like the first big show in phoenix since
cove it happened that she was huge it
was like ten thousand people i know and
there was only supposed to be like
seven thousand it was like ten thousand
they busted the gate down yeah they
knocked the gate down so hello people
were there they didn't pay that [ __ ] was
it oh my god just come [ __ ] it yeah just
pull up you don't need a ticket this
[ __ ]
just comes this [ __ ] crazy out here were
you there when like the mic got dropped
and everyone started freaking the [ __ ]
out standing on the speaker
oh man and then that's what that
[ __ ] i was looking at people up
under me running into the
you know like the crossbows that be
crossing people running
boom boom
getting knocked down like my [ __ ]
security guard snatched me down
[ __ ] made like a a [ __ ] tp on top
of me they really thought somebody was
shocked
i'm like bro get off me i don't like how
y'all man handling me
the night before that in san diego they
start fighting in the club
you feel me they snatch me off the stage
in the club i'm like bro y'all keep
doing me like that i'm
six foot like you're not a [ __ ]
average you're not a [ __ ] athlete man
right i'm gonna get down bro stop don't
be snatching but i love them you feel me
they doing what they supposed to do
but it's just like that's yeah that show
looked crazy happening you know how that
[ __ ] go man